i looked up and i could see two guys
with a
pkm belt fed
russian machine gun and they were
hammering down
on the lads my rifle only shoots 1500
meters
so i had to i called it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in
remember the first mission you were sent
on yeah i can it was in iraq
we're in the maisan desert and the mesan
desert
is a vast vast place
and it's desolate we were getting
scouted
by um a motorbike and every time we saw
this motorbike
loads of mortars were coming the
artillery and the mortars were getting
pretty damn close and then i got the
green light to um
take the target out um i saw
he was on a motorbike the hardest bit
about the shot was heat shimmer
because if you ever see somebody walking
in the desert they look slightly they
look really tall
and as they come towards you they shrink
to their normal size
so he was 675 yards away
i shot um missed my first shot second
shot i got him
and then i had to go up to the body to
to see if i'd um
if he he was you know dead
and i remember walking up to the body um
the motorbike
the the throttle was stuck in the sand
and
the bike was revving and an ak strapped
to it
and uh the guy was on the floor
and he he passed away um
he had shot him here
yeah weird weird feeling weird feeling
you feel like you're in trouble
you feel i've just killed someone
i feel in trouble and that feeling never
left you you know
when i got back to the the vehicles um
we bagged and tagged the guy
he had loads of hint on him he had been
following us for days and days
um but people are thanking you going oh
yeah good shot
tapping your shoulders good shot good
you know good mission there craig well
done
but you just killed someone you know and
it took easy a week to realize that no
one's going to tap on my shoulder and
gun can we have a quick word
you've done something wrong you know um
yeah well strange feeling strange
feeling
you said snipers working in pairs yes
they do yeah can you explain
that for me you have one and number two
now number two is
he's usually the best sniper because
he'll work out all your calculations
he'll work out all the wind
everything you need to know for your
scope and basically then he will tell
you to put it in
and all you've got to do is pull the
trigger the number one is probably the
best shooter
we gotta understand then that snipering
is not all about
shooting and killing the first job of a
sniper
is to gather lifetime information
of the battlefield so i'd look for my
scope i'd see
a bloke come out of his compound with
his with a lady
and i would make up a story say oh
there's limpy john with his wife and it
keeps your mind occupied and goes oh
let's see what bevel's doing and then
you go over to bevel
oh let's see what bob's doing oh yeah
there's bob
doing the same old thing and you get to
know their routine it's like i said you
get to know
lifetime information of the battlefield
it's quite hard really because
when you do get to take the target out
you're killing bob
you know and you've made a name up for
him for the last four days
you know but that's the sort of thing
you need to mentally switch off
so when you're you said you spent was it
four days at least in that in that spot
there for four days to start off with
put it that way
um and i was in the same position it was
a cat nap for the day
roughly about 15 minutes through the day
you end up pissing
um i dug a like a trough between my legs
and i had saws down here and inside my
legs onto your
your piss is quite acidic as well you
know but it gets to the point where you
do need a poo
and um you can't really move you can't
take your eye off the glass
you got to keep on target you work as a
pair so you just roll over and
he helps you basically he's um we'll put
a little tupperware tub under your bum
off he goes he'll wipe you and then you
crack on with your mission
i said that's how important snipering is
this was early on in my last tour we had
to give
overwatch for the afghan army
to move into this village now the afghan
army
were the mixture of british soldiers
helping them train
so this was just a mission to go into
this village to
move insurgents out the officer was
there
and he could see
that in the village itself was just full
of insurgents
absolutely full of them and
he warned the the patrol was walking
into a kill zone
now kill zone is where it's easy
to kill you basically it's a zone of
land where it's open you've got nothing
to hide
or know where to hide so i say and then
they can just mow you down
and that's the kill zone and they moved
into this kill zone
and they got opened up on and i could
see
a flicker in the distance
and i couldn't work out what it was
anywhere i got my scope on
to the uh the flicker and it was a
an insurgent with a radio hitting the
flicker was the antenna
as i was looking at the lads in the
vehicle see if they were getting out
because no shots were getting fired
i could see random splashes
happening and i was wondering what they
were and i was looking everywhere
everywhere that i engaged the target i
was looking i couldn't find anything
the only place i didn't look is where i
saw the guy with the radio
and i looked up and i could see two guys
with a pkm
belt fed russian machine gun
and they were hammering down on the lads
and it was a long way it was 2475 meters
away which is just over a mile and a
half
now my rifle only shoots 1500 meters
so i had to i caught it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in
took me nine shots to get there because
i was bracketing and what bracketing is
is that you fire the first shot see
where it lands add a bit more on
add a bit more on add a bit more until
you hit it and i managed to hit the
compound wall
so i fired and i could see it
just hit next to him so i fired again
as i fired again he stood up and
i i hit him here he fell backwards
and then the second guy stood up and i
fired a third shot
and as i fired my third shot i moved my
rifle across
and i fought a full shot so now i've got
two bullets in the air at the same time
third one missed fourth one hit him and
it hit him in the side
it was 2475 meters now i didn't know
i built the world record i didn't know
at all
i didn't know until my medals parade do
you feel proud of that
uh no not at all doing my job trying to
save 12 guys
that was it let's let's go through some
of the other
missions you're on are there any to
stand on your head as
dangerous one mission we were in basra
palace
and we got go to this place called the
p-joc and
the p-drop basically is just run by 15
people
that's it and it's next to a prison and
it used to get smashed
every single night from
eleven o'clock at night or five in the
morning it is
the gates of hell the gates of hell
and they're trying to release all these
insurgents
all these other hierarchy um
taliban from this prison and it was our
job to not let him do that and it sort
of gave the locals a bit of
um security as well knowing that
you know that soldiers were there
protecting the prison as well so there
was no
chance of escape there was no chance it
was getting liberated and overrun
we were on the roof
on this occasion you know we was using
the machine guns on both sides because
soon as they hear a sniper shot
they all run off so i told the machine
guns to start firing
the gym piece to start firing and it
masks our shots
and they came from north they came from
the south they came from the east they
came from the west they came from
everywhere
and um we got absolutely
i'm gonna say we got absolutely smashed
we thought we were gonna get overrun
so i phoned tanya
i get a bit upset you know sorry um
i phoned her and she answered
and um and i said to her i love you you
know
then she goes i know she goes what's
what noise
and i said that has nothing that's
nothing
i said i'll phone you in the morning i
promise you i'll phone you in the
morning
i just want to hear a voice you know
just wanted to hear
her voice and we went back on the roof
and yeah we were in the fight
did you call your with your wife yeah i
did yeah
yeah i didn't really tell her what was
going on
we just had a little chat i said i just
had a little
little um little wobble what's to call
it a little wobble just wanted to hear
your voice that was all
you know it's tough out here it's
because yeah i'm always here for you
like like she is now you know it was
like a wall
got shattered and when that wall of ice
got shattered
everything that i've experienced in my
tools
through bosnia kosovo um iraq afghan
i couldn't i couldn't stop it
my wife noticed it first she knows
there's something wrong due to my
isolation
my snappiness my
just depression really and suicidal
thoughts
i'm not gonna lie i will cry later
because a lot of memories come up
you know a lot of thoughts
i don't i don't disguise it you know i'm
a big advocate for
ptsd but i find i'm ashamed to have ptsd
and i i'm the first one to admit it
ruins your sex life
it ruins your home life
ruins your friends because no one wants
to be around you because you're just
miserable
you don't want to go out because you get
so angry so quick
the army noticed it and i got called
into the
mo's office which is the medical
officer's office
and then you sit there and they look at
your medical records and they go
okay stamp it you've gone from doing
20 odd years took half an hour for me
to get kicked out my um
yeah i i'll say it my wife
we went to america
um stayed there for a bit and um
my wife went back to england to see your
mum
and i uh yeah i nearly shot myself
i took all the rounds out the gun i was
practicing where to do it
where i would do it and um
i put the bullet in cocked it put it in
my mouth
and betsy was sat on the back of the
sofa
she's um little yorkshire terrier
used to run ten miles a day
like five miles out five miles back and
she used to run with me
she's um 15 now and her head tilted
until the other way and i just stared at
her
yeah i sold it sold it got rid of it
saved my life
i wouldn't be here now
either sat talking to you guys or
on this planet if it wasn't for my wife
and my dog
no [ __ ] way i'd have checked out
it's hard it's hard it's hard
we then deployed to kosovo uh that was
peacekeeping
and then from there we then deployed to
uh
afghanistan to helix ten to a completely
different
operations all together from armoured to
foot
well you've been through quite a lot on
them yeah